nocturne le bois le nouveau directeur
national de santé publique du québec
bonsoir bonsoir monsieur bon pour
première question d'abord avant
d'arriver à vos recommandations sur les
allègements ou pas est-ce qu'on est
effectivement arrivé au pic des
hospitalisations et que à partir de
maintenant vous croyez que ça voir
redescendre en fait on l'espère les
données nous montrent que en toute
vraisemblance de on serait déjà en
décroissance au niveau des
hospitalisations mais ce pas longtemps
alors faut rester prudent avec ça mais
normalement ça devrait continuer à
descendre de sorte que ce que ça veut
dire c'est que le nombre de cas de cole
dans la communauté qui eût juillet en
arrière de nous parce que ça sent
toujours quelques jours avant de
transformer en maladie assez graves pour
justifier de spécialisation alors on a
commencé à descendre des les projections
qui sont sortis aujourd'hui de police
national d'excellence en santé et
services sociaux ce qu'on appelle
doubiste donc ça devrait continuer à
descendre mais pas un rythme qui est
fulgurant leur faut attendre encore
quelques jours pour voir si
effectivement 7,7 cependant s'accentuer
et à ce moment là où huit plus
confortable pour reconnaître le jeu
c'est là la force de la descente il
ressent marc usine opposition
alors justement c'est la question parce
qu'on voit ce qui se passe en ontario et
voit ce qu on voit ce qui se passe en
colombie-britannique quand même au
nouveau brunswick où elle aussi
l'ouverture des restaurants fin du mois
l'europe je vous en parle même pas paris
tout est rouvert londres également
pourquoi au québec vous ne la santé
publique puis monsieur legault a
beaucoup dit aujourd'hui plus que
d'habitude c'est la santé publique qui
me dicte pas le moment c'est la santé
publique qui me dicte pas le moment pour
qu'on ne peut pas annoncer quelques
allègements au québec dont on peut le
faire ailleurs en fait vous remarque
rites les années d'abord les allégements
accueilli en héros parce que l'europe
devant sow si cette vague d'une coupe de
semaine parce qu'on vit ici au québec et
ailleurs au canada
l'ontario est en avance de nous en
termes de wagons le lieu peu après deux
portes pas énormément vous regardez
notre propre situation la situation
actuellement de châu numéro un ne s'est
pas le fait d'avoir des maladies et tu
as de micron ligne en y allant jusqu'aux
tlp un risque et déjà qu'ils peuvent
être très maniable et même en mourir ça
c'est sérieux mais c'est aussi l'impact
sur le système de soins le système de
soins hospitaliers ont été peu dire
déborder comme jamais on a connu ça dans
l'histoire de ce système de santé
publique il faut rester prudent on
dépasse vraiment les seuls qu'on s'était
donné comme limite alors le maintenant
une pente s'installeront rien à perdre
et on espérait que les convives ça ne
veut pas dire qu'on n'est pas capable de
prendre des décisions ici au québec au
contraire on a toujours montré je
pensais que mon prédécesseur et les
équipes qui ont entouré du son qu'on est
capable de prendre ses décisions et le
moment aujourd'hui n'est pas le bon
chemin on dire voilà on va faire face je
vais vous montrer un tableau sur les
lits disponibles par million d'habitants
que vous connaissez mieux que moi là le
québec traîne la patte les ya moins de
lits par habitant ici qu'il y en a en
ontario quand on va voir le tableau au
japon ces douze mais lui ça au québec
c'est 1860 huet on est en queue de
peloton ce qui fait que la proportion de
licques coved au québec est plus grande
quand même en ontario un autre tableau
c'est 21% presque le quart des lits
actuellement sont occupés par des lits
covin alors qu'aux états unis ces 16
avec plus de disputes alisation ontario
13 la france est ce que c'est pour six
ans c'était mieux ce paysage le système
de santé au québec est ce que vous
seriez prêt allégé plus maintenant
c'est clair que d'abord je m'oppose
tableau de chevalet et donner ce que je
vais vous dire c'est que c'est clair que
la capacité du système de soins est un
déterminant important
vous venez de mentionner on est on est
surchargé en proportion du nombre de
l'icône et considérant que ça sadc
devenu le problème de santé publique
numéro un c'est pas un problème de santé
publique parce que il faut plus qu'on le
juste des gens de covin mais c'est aussi
ne fait beaucoup d'autres noms qui
doivent avoir accès à des services
hospitaliers y en ait des gens qui ont
ce oui on va le secteur espère y aura
beaucoup d'engagement dévouement
d'épuisement mais aussi de la souffrance
et on la voit poteau d'un système
hospitalier des gens qui attendent pour
rentrer avec des problèmes de santé qui
mérite d'être pris en considération et
des traités alors faut vraiment
s'assurer qu'on ne fait pas je surfais
sur un système hospitalier qui ne garde
que les patientes que maintenant je
comprends
c'est clair excusez moi monsieur c'est
clair que si on avait une plus grande
capacité on serait pas dans la même
disposition dont on aurait on aurait
moins d'interpellations ont fait au
niveau de ses consignes aux emile et la
disponibilité c'est pas compliqué c'est
en fonction du nombre de nouveaux
patients qui rentrent de covin justement
et la capacité des sortir et de ce côté
lognes énormément d'efforts qui sont
faits par les collègues dans tout le
système de santé en l'occurrence pour
trouver des voies de sortie plus rapide
et sécuritaire les patients qui sont
happés de la commune ou de dos problèmes
de santé donc de même de louer d'anciens
fâche celle des dents certains quand le
vus à laval pour sortir des gens des
hôpitaux pourquoi faire entrer d'autres
personnes je vous parle du passeport
vaccinale on en parle beaucoup
resto on a legend assez bien compris là
on est rendu dans les grandes surfaces
les quincailleries par exemple qui
disent c'est pas une boutique est ce que
c'est une politique de santé publique ou
c'est de la politique pour faire
comprendre non vaccinés qu'on veut
qu'ils vaccinent sûrs d eux
si on regarde les faits sur ce système
de santé leur les faits actuels le
récent est toujours actuelle c'est que i
les données vont tout temps sans cela
c'est que les patients qui sont
hospitalisés vous parliez le de tous ces
personnes sont heureuses il y en a deux
tiers sont des personnes non vaccinées
qui représente sont tout autour de
la population adulte au québec il
constitue le tien des hospitalisations
et pratiquement la moitié de ceux qui
sont aux soins intensifs dont faut
vraiment faire en sorte que les
personnes qui ne sont pas vaccinés soit
encourager à être excité et d'ailleurs
il ya des programmes et des activités
qui vont être mené qui ont des jeux
techniques qui vont être relancées avec
je pense beaucoup d'énergie pour aller
chercher le plus la conviction possible
des gens qui sont pas vexer d'épaulé
vexé de ne pas donc oui mais là dessus
sur le premier par
le cei au départ moi je me souviens
docteur arruda disait 85% joue est
responsable je vois jouer jouer jouer
content on est à 90 pour ça on va voir
les chiffres sur le 18 05 on est à 90 %
de premières doses au québec 80 et deux
de deuxième dont j'ai 36 de 3e d'eau à
quand le hacker le seuil qui va vous
permettre de dire ballon n'a plus besoin
de patois vaccinale est ce que c'est ça
pour ça
monsieur roi des démons l'occasion de
vous dire que ce n'est pas la même
maladie le micro c'est pas c'est une
autre malaise si tout oui ce cas là d'un
virus mais sous l'expression très
différentes et et le virus a assez
changer pour changer par la maladie
d'abord son expression clean et sa
sévérité bien sûr mais énormément sa
contagiosité est aussi sa résistance aux
vaccins que nous avons actuellement ce
point de résistance très fort et 25 sont
très efficaces pour prévenir d'une part
les flexions oui à un certain niveau
mais surtout le risque d'hospitalisation
et le risque d'issue dramatique comme la
mort alors les accès sont vraiment
efficaces pour ce et en particulier si
on y ajoute une dose de rappel alors si
pau la même maladie quand vous parlez de
la paraiba il avait tout à fait raison
ce qu'on appelle des mises à sion
d'imiter collective avec le micro on
doit dépasser tous ces chiffres c'est
quoi le chef
de canton quelques jours offerts par
mais on le sait c'est il considérant le
fait que deux micro et est transmissible
d'une
énorme la transmission ya personne qui
nous écoutent en ce moment qui ne
connaît pas quelqu'un soit lui même ou
quelques uns de ses proches même
beaucoup qui ont pas fait l'infection
récemment c'est
fraikin alors pour arriver à une
capacité collective de dire prévient on
est aussi mise et puis on peut tout
laisser tomber on y arrivera
probablement pour toutefois il va avoir
un niveau on va progressivement où ça va
et acceptable d'avoir acceptable pour la
société d'avoir déjà qui malheureusement
pour la plupart pratiquent un très grand
nombre font joie de poètes vacciner mais
qui vont attraper l'infection et qui
vont débouler va
au moment où on ne on n'exige rap lui un
passeport vaccinale pour aller soit-elle
saq ou dans une grande surface youn
moment où on va dire ok là on a fait ce
qu'on pouvait mais un peu dans votre
esprit cette obligation la dure combien
de temps dans mon esprit cette
obligation de dépôt à la veille d'être
levée on doit s'assurer dans la
progression du stock
je sais je sais de poltrot des joueurs
aux fausses faut s'assurer que les gens
qui sont pros vacciner le et puis ce
soit se fera vacciner aussi il faut
qu'ils développent scala être leurs
joueurs développer l'infection mais qui
a développé tous temps mais pas fait
qu'il faut réduire les édiles à réduire
leurs contacts pris par cavani 29 mai ça
c'est pour raison mais c'est aussi pour
tout le monde parce que si tout ce monde
là décident de faire une réflexion en
n1b le système de santé et évoquera et
pilot y était sur le point qui n'a quand
vous avez vu les niveaux moi je
comprends pas me demander quand est ce
qu'on va l'enlever moi je recommanderais
pas de l'enlever en ce moment mais
certainement quand le paysage oui et
contrôler population à plumes on pourra
visiter cela mais c'est pas cette
semaine allez vous recommander que ne
passe pas vaccinale implique une
troisième dont se contentent la
troisième donnera pour avoir le parc
proactive c'est une c'est une très bonne
question et les complexes le peut parce
que beaucoup de monde qui auront fait
réfection et on attend n'ai pas été
capable d'avoir que toute cette quantité
de thé spécial bébé ou via la vitesse
des données de son estime que la semaine
passée il y aurait eu quelques cents de
milliers de cas on n'est pas capable de
faire des temps spécial à tout le monde
toutefois on aussi qu'il y en a qui
savent qu'ils ont fait défection il
serait on peut le considérer des feux et
cette progression sur une troisième dose
obligatoire dans le programme final
laissez-moi y réfléchir comme il faut
avec les équipes parce que ce n'est pas
correct je sais pas s'il ya un point
d'interrogation c'est pas bientôt vous
n'exigez pas pour avoir le passeport
national valide une troisième dose
bientôt la marque à la semaine prochaine
ce qu'on exige autant qu'ils veulent
exprimer ce qu'on recommande qui voulant
pas assez pour écuries le monde c'est
allez vous faire vacciner vous allez
tirer tellement bénéfices avec ce pour
vous de vous protéger mais aussi pour
votre collectivité mais très bien de
deux choses avant de vous laisser aller
docteur brûlot pourquoi il ya autant de
morts le le mort dans les sept derniers
jours taux de décès par million
d'habitants le québec vient devant les
états unis devant l'italie à 7,6 pas
remis en état pour quoi et autant de
morts maintenant au québec écoutez de
banlieue beaucoup de morts parce que ya
énormément de gens qui sont infectés
puis regardez les hôpitaux qui déborde
avec tous ces codes à arras et c'est
normal qu'ils en aient qui est des
issues très lourd comme mais pas plus
qu'ailleurs
c'est à dire les chiffres en main qu'on
utilise deux solides tôt par cent mille
satire boulot on a pour lui deux morts
au québec en proportion que ce qu'on
trouve dans d'autres juridictions se
soit l'ontario wire compris le québec
enregistre beaucoup plus les corps
prennent les cas par l'épidémie roger
prennent tous les cas mais ça ne veut
pas dire qu'il ya des morts de la cause
directe bien sûr que des membres
associés ou si halak au but de pato de
gens qui ont différents maladie mais qui
en plus à une crue et impôts dedans très
dense de location le mets moi
surmortalité voix tendre les chiffres de
chair mortalité est là dessus sur la
surmortalité plus tôt cet après-midi de
premier ministre il y ait des études
très bien fait de délaisser si québec
montrent que notre sûrement terme martin
et sur la colite canal et les deux
dernières années ont été bien meilleurs
que bien plus bien d'autres juridictions
et en particulier les etats-unis mènent
que le canada et même que l'ontario donc
on a trois une inquiétude de ce côté là
je vous ai
très bien avez-vous des données avez
vous assez de données sur la qualité de
l'air dans les salles de classe pour
être satisfait docteur boileau
si on a assez donné on a beaucoup et il
ya un souci ces lieux qui est menée par
les autorités du ministère d'éducation
éclairant et de tous les réseaux
scolaires pour faire en sorte de
s'assurer que les meilleures conditions
ce remise l'erap aux fins de la
ventilation dans les écoles auront lieu
dès des progrès de ce côté là qui ont
été faits et assuré la présence des
changeurs lario des technologies des
fois que les gens revendiquent et qui
ont pas beaucoup d'effet et même qui
pourrait être un peu dangereuse mais le
ministère de l'éducation distribuer
beaucoup des capteurs de co2
est à l'aise avec la situation actuelle
moi je pense que la situation actuelle
n'est pas une situation dramatique et
une situation complexe qui mérite des
corrigés avec une progression sérieuse
et le leadership qui brille je capotais
l'application est sérieux de ce type de
support les jeunes attendent ça avec
impatience que vous débloquez le support
reçoit des témoignages
très émotive de janequin peuvent plus et
ils ont raison les yeux quelque chose de
ce côté de qu'on souhaite vraiment
ouvrir mais on est toujours dans mes
idées mais lui on augmente les contacts
dans la communauté que ce soit ce point
jeunes au turbin est malade si les
jeunes amènent sur à d'autres de satoshi
zoo mais plus on augmente les compteurs
et on augmente les risques de prix
augmenter tous ces cas là et nous faire
des six déstabiliser site indien on le
regarde attentivement on espère être
capable de donner et bonne nouvelle pour
toutes ces personnes là le plus vite
possible et on y passe toutes nos
énergies et - 1er mai je suis pas un
seul lieu toutes uniques et la dernière
équipe solide qu'on regarde ça avec
attention
qui lui même est indépendante un
indépendant
dr directeur totalement dépendants
directeur national de santé publique du
québec j'ai promis de vous laisser
allait 17h15 à 17h15 merci merci d'avoir
été avec nous
à la prochaine pour voir nos émissions
en entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici
et redit